ich denke es ist eine extrem spannende
Sportart die für viele Jugendliche die
so wie ich sie nicht für eine Sportart
entscheiden wollen oder können
perfekt ist
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim Sport Podcast
des österreichischen Bundesheers heute
zu Gast Zugführer Gustav gusternau
herzlich willkommen guten Morgen vielen
Dank für die Einladung liebe Grüße du
bist moderner Fünfkämpfer damit sehr
vielseitig aufgestellt wir werden heute
ein bisschen über dich erfahren und über
deine Sportart du bist erst vor kurzem
nach einer schwierigen Situation bei der
Europameisterschaft in Budapest im
September ins Finale gekommen lass
einmal dieses Sohn 2021 20 20 so ein
bisschen Revue passieren genau also ich
habe nach den letzten Olympischen
Spielen 2021 eine längere Trainingspause
gemacht und bin dann etwas später erst
in die Saison eingestiegen
ich habe dann den ganzen Sommer über
leider mit einer mühsamen Knieverletzung
zu kämpfen gehabt und bin deswegen dann
eigentlich den ganzen Sommer über
ausgefallen und habe dann noch einen
Wettkampf gehabt das war die
Europameisterschaft Mitte September im
Budapest wo ich dann eigentlich einen
ganz guten Wettkampf noch gemacht habe
mich fürs Finale qualifiziert und dort
den 24 Platz erreicht aber für mich
persönlich das wichtigste ist gewesen
dass jetzt diese Verletzung Gott sei
Dank ausgesehen konnte und jetzt so 100%
fit in die neue Saison starten konnte
das klingt so als wärst du zufrieden mit
an dieser Platzierung oder trotzdem so
eine starke Leistung bekommen hast na
ich glaube ja Anbetracht der
Vorbereitung war das sicherlich eine
gute Platzierung ich bin jetzt
mittlerweile 25 Jahre alt und habe mir
mittlerweile eine ganz gute organische
Grundlage geschaffen von der ich auch in
längeren
Pausenzeiten oder verletzungsphasen
sicherlich sehr kann und ich habe dann
versucht dort meine Schwächen die ich
vielleicht durch den Trainingsrückstand
aufgerissen habe durch
bessere technische Disziplinen am
kompensieren zu können ist es so dass
man danach so einer längeren
Verletzungspause eher den Druck hat dass
man wieder befangen muss oder eigentlich
die Lockerheit
weil hauptsache ich kann jetzt wieder in
die Belastung gehen wieder alles geben
ich würde sagen sowohl als auch also bei
mir hat ein bisschen die Ungewissheit
überwogen weil hier doch den großen
Mannes Trainings auch alleine machen und
jetzt nicht wirklich viele
Vergleichswerte habt zur anderen
Weltkörper Athleten deswegen war es in
meinem Fall so dass mich dann auch schon
sehr gefreut habe auf dem Wettkampf weil
es der erste Wettkampf im Prinzip
gewesen ist seit dem letzten Olympischen
Spielen in Tokio
und ja im Nachhinein bin ich froh
gewesen dass das ganze dann auch so gut
ausgegangen ist das gerade angesprochen
dass du dein Training großes alleine
machst liegt es daran dass einfach so
üblich ist moderne Fünfkampf oder weil
es einfach in Österreich nicht so eine
große Dichte an der Spitze gibt nein im
internationalen Vergleich gehe ich da
ein bisschen so meinen eigenen Weg der
Fünfkampf ist in Österreich ja
bekanntlich eine regelrechte Exoten
Sportart und jetzt nicht so eine
Mainstream Sport hat wie Tennis oder
Schwimmen beispielsweise oder auch
Skifahren natürlich deswegen ist mit dem
Fünfkampf Training in Österreich sehr
viel Aufwand verbunden sehr viel
Individualität aber ich glaube ich an
meinen letzten Jahren ein Umfeld
geschaffen im Bereich Südstadt und in
meinem Heimatort wieder Neustadt mit
sehr guten Tränen wo ich es geschafft
habe mein Fünfkampf Training
professionelle aufzuziehen und dazu
kommt natürlich auch dass ich darauf
angewiesen bin dass ich von anderen
Nationen eingeladen wird um mit ihnen
auch gemeinsam ab und zu dann Training
im Ausland zu machen wie wertvoll sind
dann diese Trainingslehrgänge oder mit
den besten der Welt mit trainieren
kannst die sind sehr wertvoll ich bin
zum Beispiel sehr oft in Paris mit dem
französischen nationaltrum auf
Trainingskursen und es ist ab und zu
auch wichtig dass man einen
Tapetenwechsel laut dem seinem Training
dass man ein bisschen rauskommt dass
seinen eigenen vier Wänden und natürlich
auch dass man die Vergleichswerte hat
mit den besten Athleten auf der Welt
moderner Fünfkampf diese in Österreich
wie du schon gesagt dass an der
Randsportart hat aber fünf Disziplinen
Fechten Reiten Schwimmen schießen und
laufen das wäre ja per se so jetzt gar
nicht so exotisch aber die Kombination
macht das aus wie kommt man zu seiner
Sportart
naja über Umwege also in meinem Fall war
so dass ich als Kind schon immer
möglichst viele Sportarten ausprobieren
wollt also mich begonnen habe mit dem
Sport war ich am Ende der
Eishockeyspieler ich habe Judo gemacht
habe dann rechtzeitig begonnen mit dem
Laufen und mit dem Schwimmen und es ist
ja nicht so dass man jetzt alle 50
Disziplinen gleichzeitig anfängt man
fängt einmal an mit Laufen und Schwimmen
dann kommt einmal das Schießen dazu dann
das Fechten und am Schluss eines reiten
und in Österreich ist es so dass der
Fünfkampf auch nicht flächendeckend
überall ausgibt wird sondern die
Trainingszentren befinden sich ungefähr
so auf der Achse zwischen Wien Südstadt
Wiener Neustadt und Graz und Wiener
Neustadt hat sich dann in den letzten
Jahrzehnten so ein bisschen als die fünf
Hochburgen in Österreich durchsetzen
können und ich bin dann über einen
Freund einmal zum Fünfkampf Training
gekommen und bin dann so mit 12 13
Jahren dort hängen geblieben ich habe
dann mich noch entscheiden müssen ob ich
eine Eishockey Karriere nachgeben mit 12
13 und ob ich dann den Schritt ins
Ausland wagt beispielsweise und habe
mich dann dagegen entschieden und für
eine Karriere bei Modernen Fünfkampf
aber das heißt auch dass die in dem
Alter bewusst gewesen sein musste dass
du eben moderner fünf Kämpfer werden
wirst dass ich das nicht das irgendwie
ergibt sondern du möchtest diese spart
dazu betreiben es war bis zu einem
gewissen Grad so also die Vorzeichen
waren damals noch andere mit wie ich 12
13 Jahre alt gewesen bin hat es noch
eine sehr große fünfkampfgruppe gegeben
mit sehr vielen Gleichaltrigen die den
Sport mit mir gemeinsam mit der
Trainingsgruppe ausgeübt haben aber es
lässt sich natürlich damals noch nicht
absehen wie die Dinge so entwickeln und
in meinem Fall bin ich froh gewesen dass
ich ziemlich dann letztendlich für den
Fünfkampf so entschieden habe
da hast du vorher schon gesagt Eishockey
Judo ganz ganz viele Dinge
offensichtlich bist du ein sehr
vielseitiger Sportler auch neben deinem
aktiven Sport oder von der Fähigkeiten
her ist das glaubst du
Grundvoraussetzung wenn man wirklich
guter moderner Fünfkämpfer zu werden
genau also ich glaube das liegt in der
Natur der Sache ein bisschen und für
mich bietet das einen unglaublichen Reiz
weil beim Fünfkampf seine extrem
facettenreiche Sportart man muss zum
Beispiel im Laufe von dem Schwimmen
organisch sehr gut drauf sein und
braucht Kraft und Ausdauer dann braucht
man im Schießen z.B wieder eine mentale
Stärke das Vermächtnis sehr technisch
geprägt und dann kommt natürlich noch
das Reiten dazu wo der Umgang mit einem
Lebewesen gefragt ist und das edelt für
mich diese Sportart wirklich so perfekt
ab aber diese Sportart ist auch vielen
Veränderungen ausgesetzt und
wahrscheinlich bist es schon ein
bisschen müde über diese Dinge zu reden
oder zu hören weil es natürlich dich und
euch direkt betrifft in den letzten
Jahren ist immer wieder auch zum
Beispiel das Laufen und das Schießen
verändert worden als den
kombinationsbewerb dann gab das heißt
dass man das gemeinsam macht wie stellt
man sich auf solche Änderungen an auch
Änderungen die auch noch kommen über die
wir auch noch gleich reden aber ähm wie
trainiert man diesen Sport wenn man
plötzlich weiß okay jetzt sind nicht
mehr zwei einzelne Disziplin sondern ich
muss jetzt kombiniert trainieren das
heißt ein bisschen wie beim Biathlon
dass ich aus dem laufen muss
es ist für das Trainerteam und für die
Athleten eine sehr große Herausforderung
sich auf diese ständigen Regeländerungen
darauf einzustellen und wenn man sich
anschaut wie der Sport
1912 also das erste Mal im olympischen
Programm gestanden ist
ausgeschaut hat und die Form wie er
jetzt letztes Jahr ein Tokio über die
Bühne gegangen ist da muss man schon
feststellen dass er sich in wesentlichen
Bereichen verändert hat zum Beispiel hat
man früher den reitbewerb über fester
Hindernisse gehabt in Form einer
Geländeprüfung dann ist man noch 300
Meter geschwommen Schatz 200 Meter das
Laufen und Schießen war wie bereits
erwähnt noch getrennt beides für sich
geschossen aber mit Kleinkaliber damals
der schießt man mit Laserpistolen ich
glaube das ist auch wichtig dass man die
Sportart immer wieder kleineren Reformen
aussetzt und zeitgemäß zu bleiben aber
speziell für die Planung bedeutet das
natürlich dass man dann sein Training
auch dementsprechend immer wieder
adoptieren muss das muss jetzt gar nicht
so
größere Reformen sein wie dass man zum
Beispiel eine komplette Sportart raus
streicht es reicht ja dass man zum
Beispiel die schwimmpunkte halbiert dass
man das ein Training dann schon
dementsprechend anpasst aber ich habe
ein sehr großes und gutes Trainerteam
die das bis jetzt Gott sei Dank
hervorragend gemacht haben schön Punkte
halbieren heißt das die schwimmbewerbe
oder die die Zeit immer das stimmt jetzt
nicht so gewichtig dann sind und man
vielleicht den Fokus eher auf die
anderen Dinge gelegt weil die dann
wahrscheinlich Wettkampf entscheidet
werden oder so solche Dinge meinst du
richtig also diese Serie Form ist ich
glaube vor fünf Jahren gekommen und das
hat mich persönlich sehr stark betroffen
weil ich einen Hintergrund habe beim
Schwimmen ich habe als Kind mit dem
Schwimmen eigentlich begonnen bin
sondern zum Fünfkampf gekommen und mir
wäre natürlich lieber gewesen dass sie
laufpunkte halbieren und die fünf Punkte
verdoppeln aber es ist leider kein
Wunschkonzert es ist kein Wunschkonzert
aber wenn es eines wäre was wäre der
optimale moderne Fünfkampf wie würdest
du ihn aufstellen damit er modern bleibt
aber auch seine Wurzeln nicht verleugnet
oder seine gute Frage
ich würde sagen dass der Fünfkampf so
wird in den letzten Jahren am
stattgefunden hat und so wie er
ursprünglich gedacht gewesen ist also
dass er wirklich versucht den kompletten
Athleten hervorzubringen und es war auch
der Ursprungsgedanke von Baron Pierre
der kubaital dem Erfinder der
Olympischen Spiele der Neuzeit für mich
steht zum Beispiel außer Frage dass die
Disziplinen so wie sie bis jetzt am
gewesen sind beibehaltet werden müssen
natürlich müssen Reformen gemacht werden
vielleicht würde ich bei der
Punkteverteilung etwas ändern dass es
mir ein wenig entgegenkommt mit meinen
Stärken und Schwächen aber ich finde das
der Fünfkampf so wie er ursprünglich
gedacht gewesen ist eigentlich perfekt
gewesen ist und jetzt natürlich auch
dementsprechend adaptiert werden muss
und auch zeitgemäß gestaltet werden muss
aber das heißt dieser Gedanke den
kompletten Athleten die komplette
Athletin zu zeigen siehst du in seiner
ursprüngliche Form bloß natürlich ein
paar Formen gut abgedeckt ja also in der
Entstehungsgeschichte von modernen
Fünfgang wieder 1912 das erste Mal bei
den Olympischen Spielen gewesen war es
so dass wenn man sich so die Disziplinen
anschaut also laufen schwimmen
Fähigkeiten schießen reiten sind alles
Fähigkeiten gewesen die ein Soldat in
seiner Entstehungszeit gekonnt haben
muss und man sieht daher auch schon den
sehr starken Bezug zum Militär und wie
bereits vorher schon erwähnt habe ist
damit mit dieser Sportart eigentlich das
gesamte Facettenreichtum sehr schön
abgedeckt und für mich daher wirklich
ein perfekter Sport jetzt kommen wir zur
Diskussion jetzt schon seit den
Olympischen Spielen in Tokio
vorherrscht und auch es wirkt einen
Höhepunkt gefunden hat das Reiten wird
aus dem Programm gestrichen nach den
Olympischen Spielen 2024 und sie
versetzt durch einen
Hindernisparcours wieder ausgeschaltet
ist das glaube ich noch nicht ganz klar
ist das in dem Sinne noch der perfekte
Sport ohne die Reiterei
ja schwer zu sagen also die so einen
klavierende Umänderung der Sport oder
das in der Geschichte des modernen fünf
Kampfs de facto nie gegeben
man muss natürlich auch sagen an dieser
Stelle dass die
Vorfälle in Tokio nicht von heute auf
morgen passiert sind sondern dass
eigentlich schon Jahre zuvor
negative Entwicklung aufgetreten sind
und dass die Vorfälle in Tokio
eigentlich nur ein Resultat dessen
gewesen sind jetzt gilt natürlich die
Sportler zu weit wie möglich zu
reformieren und diesen neuen Bewerb
diesen Hindernisparcours oder Ninja
Warrior versuchen in das gesamte
Sportbild dazu integrieren und für mich
war natürlich auch die Auswahl der neuen
Sportler dieses Ninja Warrior jetzt
keine große Überraschung weil man
braucht sie nur anzuschauen welche
Sportarten jetzt in den letzten Jahren
in olympische Programme aufgenommen
worden sind den Sportarten wie zum
Beispiel es geht worden oder auch
Wellenreiten ich glaube jetzt kommt
keine surfen dazu also regelrechte
Trendsportarten die so ein bisschen den
Zeitgeist auch entsprechen und für mich
fügt sich dann Ninja Warri eigentlich da
ganz gut in dieses Bild ein und das
heißt im Endeffekt eine
modernisierendere Aufwertung die
vielleicht dazu für das jüngere
Zielgruppen dann den modernen fünf Kampf
schauen oder zumindest den Teil des
Ninja Warriors für euch aber du hast ja
natürlich jetzt angesprochen dass diese
Entwicklung auch über die Jahre passiert
ist ist dir das mal passiert dass du bei
einem Wettkampf gut unterwegs warst und
dann ein Pferd zugelost bekommen hast
das nicht so wollte wie du es gebraucht
hättest für eine super Ergebnis kommt
das oft vor
ich glaube die Anforderungen die an die
Athleten mit diesen fremden Pferden
gestellt werden sind sehr hoch ich
glaube jeder fünf Kämpfer der die
Sportart über Jahre hinweg in Weltcup
Zirkus am ausübt kommt schon mal vor
dass er ein Pferd zieht mit dem man
nicht so gut zurechtkommt aber ich
glaube auch da muss man das Beste aus
der Situation machen ich glaube in den
letzten Jahren ist vor allem seitens des
internationalen fünfkampfverbandes es
war absäumt geworden da schon
rechtzeitig entgegenzuwirken um den
reitbewerb zeitgerecht zu gestalten man
hätte da meiner Meinung nach viel enger
mit den nationalen reitsportverbänden
kooperieren müssen mehr Zeit und Geld
investieren müssen um das Niveau von
Pferden Reiter einen entsprechendes
Niveau sicherzustellen und anzuheben
und auf der anderen Seite hat man immer
wieder begonnen
unter Anführungszeichen kleinere Exoten
Nationen in den Weltverband mit
aufzunehmen die defact mit ihren
Ressourcen keine Chance gehabt haben
dieses Niveau und diesen Anforderungen
hier gerecht zu werden und diese beiden
sage mal entgegengesetzten Entwicklungen
also auf der einen Seite dass das dass
man das Niveau hätte anheben müssen und
auf der anderen Seite diese Exoten
Länder die das Niveau etwas abgesenkt
haben haben dann letztendlich zu diesen
Entwicklungen geführt ich sehe hier
spricht der zukünftige moderne
fünfkampfverband Präsident machst du
offensichtlich auch sehr viele Gedanken
um deinen Sport man sieht doch dass du
diese Passion dafür hast jetzt ist noch
in der alten Form mit dem Reiten und
danach kommt eben dahin ist Parcours wie
stellst du dich jetzt sportlich darauf
ein kann man jetzt überhaupt noch so
viel investieren Reitsport oder muss man
jetzt schon in die Zukunft denken an die
Spiele 2028 in Los Angeles
also für mich haben die jüngsten
Entscheidungen dass man den reitbewerb
streicht und eine neue Disziplin da
evaluiert de fact überhaupt keine
Auswirkungen gehen gehabt für meine
Vorbereitung für Paris wie gesagt das
ist ja noch im alten Format und meine
Vorbereitungen laufen wie gewohnt weiter
also ich investiere zu 100 Prozent in
den reitbewerb und alles was danach
kommt ist noch Zukunftsmusik aber
glaubst du gibt es Kollegen von dir die
sagen ich möchte Los Angeles alle
überraschen das heißt diese zwei Jahre
die die schenke ich mir jetzt und ich
gehe jetzt schon auf das Training für
den hindernisverkauf immer noch nicht
ganz genau weiß wie das sein wird und
dann einfach Vorsprung zu haben auf die
anderen gibt's das ich denke schon im
international Vergleich vor allem die
jüngeren Athleten für die vielleicht
Pariser 24 jetzt noch nicht ein Thema
ist aber die sich für 28 dann
vorbereiten wollen ich glaube dass in
der Hinsicht auch der Verband gefragt
ist weil der muss jetzt versuchen auch
sein Trainingsumfeld dementsprechend
anzupassen und einmal
den hindernisparatur organisieren und
sich Material anschaffen dass man danach
dann dementsprechend trainieren kann zur
Auswahl standen auch mögliche Rat
Bewerbe das wäre wahrscheinlich dem mit
dem weiten ein bisschen mehr dran
gewesen zumindest eine Idee dass das
Fortbewegungsmittel hätte das auch
gefallen
eigentlich nicht weil für mich wäre das
dann eher so ein Triathlon plus gewesen
Lauf von schwimmen gibt es schon in der
Sportart dann wäre Radfahren auch noch
dazu gekommen dazu noch Fechten und
schießen also ich glaube von allen
Sportarten die hier zur Auswahl
gestanden sind glaube ich hat man mit
dem Hindernisparcours eine attraktive
neue Disziplin ins Programm aufgenommen
ich persönlich hätte man vielleicht noch
eine andere Disziplin wünschen können
wie zum Beispiel Eishockey ich glaube da
hätte ich vielleicht die mindestens
nationalen Vergleich ein bisschen einen
Vorsprung schon gehabt als Schnelllauf
wäre doch auch gute gegangen hat sich
auch einen guten Vortrag gehabt jetzt
hast du ihn Tokio am 16 Platz bis knapp
davor noch am 8 Platz gelegen ist dein
Fazit jetzt unabhängig von diesen ganzen
medialen
Lichte blicken auf eurer Sport hat mit
deiner Leistung gewesen
also ich glaube der 16 Platz bei den
Olympischen Spielen war mein bisheriger
Karrierehöhepunkt in meiner Sportart
gibt's leider keine US Open oder keine
Streife Abfahrt oder keine
Vierschanzentournee
das sind Olympische Spiele die einzige
Möglichkeit um seine Sport oder auf
einer großen Bühne zu präsentieren und
für mich war die Qualifikation per se
schon ein riesengroßer Erfolg ich habe
mich als 35 davon 36
denkbar knapp als einer der jüngsten für
den Hauptbewerb dann qualifizieren
können und das 16 Platz war dann für
mich noch einmal die Draufgabe aber das
heißt auch dass du noch ganz viel
Potenzial hast wo geht deine olympische
Reise hin
ich glaube dass ich jetzt so mit 25
Jahren schon langsam ins beste
fünfkampfhalter komme auf der einen
Seite ist wichtig im Fünfkampf dass man
organisch gut drauf ist und da ist man
glaube ich jetzt dann so mitte ende 20
im besten Alter auf der anderen Seite
ist wichtig dass man auch eine nötige
Routine sich über die Jahre aufbaut die
vor allem im fechtbewerb oder auch im
Reiten oder im Schießen wichtig ist also
ich glaube das jetzt vor allem im
letzten Saison noch einen guten Schritt
nach vorne gemacht habe und das Ziel ist
natürlich dass ich dann in Paris in zwei
Jahren hoffentlich dabei bin und den
Platz noch mal verbessern kann wie
schaut seine Olympiaqualifikation im
modernen fünf Kampf aus
es gibt die Möglichkeit dass man sich
direkt qualifiziert für die Spieler das
ist im Fall bei Modernen Fünfkampf über
die Europameisterschaft oder über die
Weltmeisterschaft das habe ich vor zwei
Jahren knapp verpasst da bin ich bei der
Europameisterschaft 13 geworden die
besten 11 haben sich damals qualifiziert
und ich habe dann quasi den zweiten
Versuch starten müssen über die
Weltrangliste und da gibt's die
Möglichkeit dass man sich über Weltcups
oder andere größere internationale
Wettkämpfe Punkte holt um so einen Platz
über die Welt ist dann bekommt und das
heißt du musst schauen dass du bei dem
einen groß eigenes deine Form hast aber
auch bei den ganzen Welt gab genug
Punkte Sammlung am Schluss auf jeden
Fall sicher in Paris zu sein doch 16
schon ausgegeben jetzt fände ich so als
als Vergleich was würdest du sagen in
den einzelnen Disziplinen auch wenn es
jetzt nicht ähm mit den reinen
Sportarten so vergleichbar sind wo wärst
du österreichweit sind im nationalen
Vergleich beim Fechten beim Schwimmen
und wo stehst du mir von der
Leistungsfähigkeit
in der Jugend ist es normalerweise
üblich dass man sich auch dann mit den
Spezialisten vergleicht da die fünf
kampfdichte in Österreich ja bekanntlich
ein bisschen überschaubar ist und da
habe ich schon begonnen mich immer
wieder zum Beispiel beim Schwimmbad
Kämpfen zu beweisen oder auch bei
fechtkämpfen
österreichweit kann ich das als für
Disziplin für Disziplin gar nicht zu
sagen weil jede Sportart per se ist für
sich sehr individuell aber ich glaube
dass man hier auch einen ganz guten
Kompromiss machen muss weil zum Beispiel
im Falle vom Schwimmen ist es so wenn
man jetzt viel schwimmen trainiert dann
baut man eher mehr Muskeln auf das ist
dann wieder Gewicht dass man beim Laufen
dann mit sich mitfahren muss auf der
anderen Seite lauft man mehr baut man
wieder ein bisschen mehr Muskeln ab dann
fehlen wieder die Kraft im Schwimmen
also ich glaube dass man hier immer
wieder versuchen muss auch sein Training
dementsprechend auszurichten
auf jeden Fall da auch Stimmen wie
würdest du neue junge Leute für deinen
Sport begeistern wollen
ich glaube das ist wichtig ist dass man
den fünf Kampf mit ja ein bisschen mehr
aufbereitet ich denke es ist eine extrem
spannende Sportart die für viele
Jugendliche die so wie ich sie nicht für
eine Sportart entscheiden wollen oder
können
perfekt ist und ich glaube dass man hier
auch auf dieser Ebene Aufklärungsarbeit
stellen muss wo es Möglichkeiten gibt
dass man den fünf Kampf trainieren kann
man muss nicht da mit allen Disziplinen
gleichzeitig anfangen kann ich das Stück
für Stück erarbeiten und im Endeffekt
ist es so dass wenn man dann mit 13 14
Jahren drauf kommt das vielleicht der
Fünfkampf doch eine Nummer zu groß ist
oder das ist spannendere Sportarten gibt
dann ist es ja kein Problem dass man
dann auch umsteigt
das heißt eine Empfehlung von dir alle
jungen polisportiven Talente in den
Modernen Fünfkampf zu bekommen das passt
auch gut zum meinen abschließenden kurz
Fragen an dich an meinen Sport
begeistert mich am meisten
die Frage ist einfach definitiv die
Abwechslung wenn ich nicht Sportler wäre
dann wäre ich
wo gute Frage ich glaube da müssen man
die Frage fast ein bisschen
umformulieren wenn ich nicht fünf
Kämpfer wäre dann wäre ich sicher also
die Spieler geworden also wirklich Profi
mit äh eine Shell Ambitionen mit Anita
Ambitionen auf jeden Fall ob es dann
soweit gekommen wäre das Letzte
natürlich nicht sagen okay aber die
Ziele die setzt du dir auf jeden Fall
meine stärkste Eigenschaft ist
meine Zielstrebigkeit und meine
Trainingseinstellung glaube ich meine
schwächste Eigenschaft ist ich bin ein
ziemlich ungeduldiger Mensch also ich
glaube dass das eine meiner Schwächen
ist dann kommt das Wort entgegen oder
hinter Dich das Wort
auf der anderen Seite ist glaube ich
wichtig im Training dass man sich nicht
zufrieden gibt mit den Leistungen auf
der anderen Seite vor allem so mentalen
Disziplinen wie schießen oder Fichten
ist es glaube ich gar nicht so schlecht
wenn man dann auch ein bisschen mehr
Ruhe oft hat
ich träume von Olympia gold
das wollen wir dir auf jeden Fall
wünschen dass ich 24 20 28 die nächsten
Chancen die auf jeden Fall angehen wirst
lieber Gustav alles Gute für deine
Zukunft herzlichen Dank dass du bei uns
beim sportrabatt hast vielen Dank für
die Einladung das hast du uns Gustav bei
uns im sparda-bad wir freuen uns wenn ja
beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid
bis dann
[Applaus]